واضح ان هناك تجري وساطات في محاوله
لانهاء هذا الاشكال الا اذا تطور على نحو
اخر
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم كتيبه جنين تدعو
لتظاهرات في عموم فلسطين للمطالبه
بالافراج عن معتقلي المقاومه لدى السلطه
وتكشف عن نقض السلطه تعهدا للافراج عن
معتقلها مقابل زياره الرئيس الفلسطيني الى
جنين ومحافظ جنين يقول للجزيره ان خلفيه
الاعتقالات جنائيه روسيا تعلن تعرض جسر
القرم المنفذ البري الاهم من شبه الجزيره
معها لهجوم اوكراني وصفته بالارهابي وتقول
انه نفذ بزورقين مسيرين وانا المهاجمين
سيحاسبون مطالبه المجتمع الدوليه
بالالتزام بتقديم تقييم ملائم للهجوم في
حين اعترفت مصادر امنيه اوكرانيه
بالمسؤوليه عنها تواصل المعارك في مدن
الخرطوم الثلاث والجيش يقصف مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريه في وسط مدينه ام درمان
وجنوبها من جانبه اكد الاتحاد الافريقي في
ختام اعمال الاجتماع التنسيقي مع
المجموعات الاقليميه ضروره تنسيق الجهود
لحل الازمه في السودان موجه حر غير مسبوقه
تضرب شمال الكره الارضيه في امريكا
واوروبا وافريقيا واسيا المنظمه العالميه
للارصاد الجويه قالت ان مطلع الشهر الجاري
كان الاسبوع الاشد حراره على الاطلاق في
كوكب الارض ما اجبر السلطات في عدد من
الدول الى اتخاذ تدابير صارمه للتعامل مع
تداعياتها الى اللقاء